welcome to this video FM mmm JY song
something no i just look for the name
but i don't find a name in that mess so
chime off yeah that's the most popular
line nowadays english attack what do we
start with Bishop e7 huh I think that's
correct him g5 actually anyway anyway Oh
interesting 45 okay so let's go ahead
and d5 was my train of thought g 597 it
seems ok yeah that's quite often an idea
a queen takes Bishop f4 traps the Queen
but that shouldn't be so bad for me now
f 4g 4s kind of embarrassing and 95 is
happening in most cases or not
mmm q I can't play Knights you form or
just castle it's actually a.m. there's
nothing really happening let's castle
hmm I can't go Knight f3 even here 19 3
Bishop b5 it's not bad but okay
I can also do this just yeah just try to
be solid down just want to keep
everything here and FYI can take G for
nothing happening here now i cant
message of this sorry let's do this one
little thing that's important that night
c for Bishop d6 Queen d6s answered by
quincy form i have to avoid that hmm can
I not just take here I cannot take I
don't know I don't know let's take and I
thought I can just play you five here or
not what is the big idea and let's do
this
efore or taking F force but was pretty
good for hmm i don't know what's better
let's play one both look pretty good
oops didn't see that one coming we
should f5
ok so maybe here I mean material is
really really fine what is that fee for
I've got three points three extra pounds
maybe just double doubling here right
I can just really push forward and f4
even rookie three maybe or not and
that's also fine i believe bit lower on
time so it's really funny and somehow
I've won all of those points yeah that's
a huge model of pawns
I thought rook air-five isn't that I'm
winning that piece
yeah that's it's simply a nice feature
of the Sicilian defense of you
especially the open Sicilian if if
things go go right for you then they
really go right yeah and sometimes can
check can get in those games where you
just totally stomp the other the other
one to the ground um how to do this now
just to just trade him no need for
profanity fancy moves time morning white
resigns yeah as I said if if things go
right they really go right yeah angry i
don't i don't really know if somewhere
around here we are still within
theoretical this is theoretical stuff
that can also take on before i believe
ya g5 is more interesting when I have to
go to age five but even that I think
it's something that is so theoretically
explored I can't even do this it's kind
of ok I believe this and this now you
Wendy five I don't say I really think it
okay I could have done this ah that's
even stronger and I even think i saw
this idea before but forgot about it
that's not bad though it's not a bad
move as f1 is failing and that means he
has to find some kind of compensation
for the big e five pawn and it's really
a big mole yeah that's winning more or
less
so well what I did is ok but it's
nothing there were many many ideas I
take it on your 5 North better and this
down here this is just just a win and
it's funny out with the other responds
thriller a real porn porn rulem gallons
wins the night tomorrow is very
interesting line really it's a it's get
it gets the typical non-symmetrical
sicilian play but it is not as sharp and
term and sometimes mind-boggling to
learn then the night overall the dragon
so what's very much recommended thanks
for watching